Good morning, Linden.
Good morning, Aman.
How are you doing?
Alright, and yourself?
Yeah, doing pretty good.
Good morning, Paul.
Ohh.
Aman Power.
Hey, Paul.
But.
What are you doing this morning?
Can't complain.
That pretty good.
At least it's Friday, right?
That's right.
Luis is going to be done.
Yeah.
Everywhere.
Natalie.
Yo, what's up?
Hey, Natalie.
You know, guys, like, when I come in, things like that.
It's refreshing. It's fantastic.
I have this guy on my shirt, the two pocket India, Amit appreciates it.
He died today.
This is RIP then.
As everything moves up.
Yeah.
Paul, I have to connect with you. I'll just get this out of the way since we're all sitting here in silence anyway. Lee did send me some pricing over and then we were thinking to review with you first or do you want us to just kind of reach out and schedule with, who do you think we should schedule with?
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
We can review it. That's fine. Set up a different call, then we'll go over it next week. Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Alright, get me the guy's name.
Yeah.
Yeah, Luis is going to be joined.
Yeah, he should be. He has a message to me.
Did I spell it right? I think I spelled it right, right.
Yeah, alright.
Yeah.
Everywhere.
Be full of morningly.
Haley.
Happy 5th day of the week, everybody!
Hi.
We made it.
Well, it's kind of the 4th day of the week now.
No, it's the 5th. Well, technically it's the 6th day of the week, depending on how you're looking at it.
Whoa, come on!
It's the 4th day of this specific work week, I guess.
Ohh, that's what it is. OK, I was just that's the way I was looking at it.
Fair enough, Linden, Paul, how you both doing?
Hey.
No.
Yeah.
Now, Paul, I don't think I saw you during the during the background challenge. Did you participate or is that shenanigans not not something you're diving into?
No.
I'm boring.
Be the coffee bean.
I like it.
Lewis, good to see you.
You too as well. And Paul, you joined. You were part of the meeting this morning. You were part of the shenanigans. Your soul was there.
Oh, was I did that strange frozen picture? Was that present somewhere? Okay.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. You were there.
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, I meant to join you guys there. No, we're trying to put together that AI governance thing next week. It's a big CFO meeting for people, so I get dragged into all these off-kilter meetings. I think I missed like two or three years meetings in a row.
Morning everyone. Paul, I was expecting a cool background for you. That's not done here. Yeah.
Everybody knows about this, except me, I guess.
I, I didn't, I didn't IM Amit to say to say something.
Yeah.
It's okay, Paul.
That's fine, I'm out of the loop. Too many things.
More things that I can check a stick at. For my part, Aman is doing great.
Never, never heard that one.
So I have no feedback regarding Aman. He's doing good. PTO's approved for his trip home. Everything should be good.
Thank you.
Oh, I think then I'll start with Lewis Linden. How's everything going?
Hold on.
Things are going okay. Obviously, we have a high volume of tickets that we need to take care of as far as we made some changes to the call system. I mean, not directly as far as call system, just the people that were involved.
So.
Yeah.
So we're involving a lot more people in...
Taking calls, tier ones and tier twos are now part of the inbound calls, which means that there's a lot of time now that's freed up for everybody because we got a lot more people involved in taking calls. You know, with that said, so that means that now allows a lot of people to do outbound calls, so that way they can
work on the tickets that they have and give them the opportunity to improve their utilization as far as whatever the tickets that exist with that said. So that's definitely changed. We also are in the process of making some changes as far as...
The.
All codes, as far as the release modes, like releasing for break, lunch, so on and so forth. To be able, it needed to be revisited. Obviously, it's been a while, at least it was never been visited by me since I've been here. So, with that, just got that cleaned up, sent an SOP out. Obviously, Aman, you saw a couple of SOPs that went out yesterday.
Yeah.
Right.
So now the team's also going to be part of pushing out and regress to standardizing the...
summary, you know, subject line for the most part as far as when they create tickets as well. So that'll be Linden and Calvin that are going to be pushing that out to make sure that that's all standardizing, getting everybody on the same page. Obviously, we're not going to retro the 400,000 plus tickets.
you know, to that degree, but going forward, we should be pretty much pushing toward making sure that we maintain that standard so that way we can do a better audit trail and so on and so forth.
Yeah, I went through both the SOP. I had a connect this morning and yesterday. So the team is fully aligned and what they need to follow. And the good thing with everything now we have a written document and process document. So everyone is aligned, but the same what they need to follow. And it's come to the regular shift or later or.
And I think this is same for Valor and Maxwell as well, right?
This will be that you shared yesterday.
Or for them as something different that you're planning or maybe Ruben is planning.
I mean, for the most part, it should be the same. As far as, you know, when they're creating their tickets, the, as far as the alert board that they respond to, taking care of the command alerts and things like that, those are.
not client facing for the most part, but they're already on a set standard as far as how they get established whenever a command alert or a ninja alert comes out as far as developing those tickets. So that's fine in that area. But as far as if they were, you know, doing the D work as far as, you know, to the ninja device health, you know, where they're creating tickets, taking care of those ones, and
Yeah, they'll most likely follow the standard in that area if they're doing any client-facing tickets, like...
Hey, I need you to help me in this, you know, obviously in that area as well. So, yeah, it should be going across really for everybody.
I got it. Yeah, we even had a connect with them in the afternoon, so...
A little clarity, I need that they are also following the same process. Yeah, good to know that. And how about Vernie and Abdul, Lindelishman, you noticed anything in this week?
how they're doing, you know, what we have discussed last week. I do see.
I think for the group report, getting every survey, and if there is any survey felt that I getting the email notification for the same. So, what is your observation for this week for both?
Most far as this week, I haven't seen any that in regards to what I have been seeing. You know, with that said, so obviously, if I see any that comes out, I'm going to pretty much CC you if the ITBD is involved, but outside of that, this week,
is different from the previous weeks where, you know, I just kept seeing the repeat offenders getting the poor crew reports.
Yeah.
Yeah, very good. And I also noticed in the weekend shift as well, yeah, they have enough tickets to work, especially on the new rollout that we have done for the ticket assignment. And either putting additional effort to check individually ticket if any customer responded ticket or anything that.
So...
They are good with that, yeah, I think, yeah, that's good. How about other, yeah, Juned and I think Vernie and Abdur doing pretty good now. How about Juned?
It's fun, never really seen anything change in terms of performance.
Um, Linden.
And do you see the number is increasing in comparison? Yeah, of course, when the other ticket count is an increase, so when I noticed available also increased ticket count also.
Yeah, because that's probably due to the number of resources. Like remember we went down, one, we no longer have Tina, so we have to take on that responsibility. So obviously utilization would increase. But yeah, I'm seeing the growth.
Thanks, sir.
Yeah, right.
Data.
Good, good. Yeah, just, I think we discussed in our last service call that Palak, but I think Amit let me know, we're still keeping Palak right, just looking the trend on the PTO, et cetera, so at least we have someone who can cover that particular shift, so she's still working.
right, taking care most of the ticket and working the same regular shift. What Abdur is working, 8 to 5. Just for your, yeah.
Yeah, so the baseline would remain the same, what we agreed upon, that when the entire team is working, she will remain on standby so that the utilization is not getting divided by her tickets. But the reason we will still keep her in the background on standby for now is to make sure.
Anybody that is, who is new in the team, right, getting time to settle in, if there are any PTOs, et cetera, she's able to cover. Once the team is settled in, of course, we can move ahead with what we discussed.
Mm.
Wait, so I think we're good. Anything else apart from this anything that new that you're implementing on the AI side? We have a lot of things here, so I want to hear from your side if you're implementing anything.
Probably. We are looking at possibly implementing a tool, but we're looking at a couple different tools we haven't quite settled just yet. It is likely we'll be bringing in a tool, something like a Neo Agent or Zofig or something like that.
On the others on the client side, we're putting together packaging around selling.
A partnership with that, so...
Yeah, if you think anything that you need from our side, Natalie is here. So our team is fully involved in a lot of new innovation on the, you know, ticket handling, tracing and everything. So do let us know whether you need anything from our side. So we can definitely support.
Yeah.
Yeah, we did discuss that with Lee at some length. If anything, it would probably be a, as we grow in it, we may have a need for like staffing. We've had good-ish results, right, with the direct model with you guys, with Nate engineers. So that would probably be where we go. I don't think we necessarily need much help with the governance strategy part.
or like the business side of that part.
Yeah.
So we'll keep you posted.
It is.
Yeah, no, that's good.
Yeah, heard, heard Paul, and I agree. I know you guys have a strong conversation around it right now. The one thing that I will ask about is, have you guys looked over the build it information? You guys thinking of coming to the to build it and or the next accelerator, because the two are kind of intertwined for this this coming August?
I don't know that we've hard planned it. As you know, I intend to go. I'm going to try to go. If I can't, I'll see if someone else can.
Okay.
Cool. Yeah, Natalie and I want to get you, Kris, Ben, whoever, whoever is interested, registered and want to help make that happen in whatever way possible. So just let us know as you.
Yeah.
Re-forward me all the details if you can.
Sure, Natalie and I, Natalie can help with that.
Yeah, I have the full agenda, so I'll break it over to you and then I'll also put in there like the partner stuff, because then you get to stay a little bit longer because you're partnering.
Yeah.
Kam.
It.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is that?
And I think, yeah, Paul, I think you, you always fill the server. I'm gonna get this month that we haven't get do let me if you have the link still, or when I get it sent that sort of month of April.
Ohh, let me see.
Right, yep.
Let me, if I can resend it for you.
Yeah, just resend it. I don't know who it came from this time, but usually I hit the green :).
Yeah, Phil all of his son.
I say, yeah, but we want to love here some comment also.
Hit the smiley Paul, wherever you see it.
Yeah.
I want my feedback. Auto uncheck the share my feedback button. That should be off by default, not on.
All right, I think then we'll jump into our agenda. Let me share my screen then.
Morris, let me know if you can see it.
Yeah, it's visible.
Right, thank you again. Welcome to our weekly service review meetings for the last week.
There's no change in the agenda. We already checked how things are going at the moment. These were the few highlights for this week and last week. So yeah, thank you, Luis, for sending out the new ticket, Kris and SOP that you have implemented and the team has been already aligned.
The microphone system, the new SOP, yeah, that's also well defined, you know, giving clear instruction to the team what they need to follow. Performance, so just overall for the month of April, the overall utilization for the entire team, excluding Aman and excluding Palak, 65% overall for the entire team.
The recent end user C set report that I checked this morning shows 98.84% for all the engineer ITBD side.
All right, so few item. I think our action tracker is reducing the numbers. So SLN KPA reporting, we have completed that. I think one piece still is in progress, Maxwell and Willer replacement. That discussion, I think, but Kris is ongoing, right?
Yeah, we spoke with Kris and Lewis a couple weeks ago, and I think they had seen some improvement, but overall, I think we're all on the same page that it will be strongest to move that direction. Lewis, have you had any new thoughts since then?
Yeah, I mean, same thing. Definitely, we are seeing improvements where Maxwell is increasing, you know, to that degree, as far as doing more additional D work to keep himself occupied. The utilization seems to be going up, you know, to that degree, so in Valor as well, so we're definitely seeing improvements versus...
you know, before, as far as whenever this conversation started to that degree. But yeah, it might, you know, pretty much be in the same path for the most part. You know, obviously we just want to make sure that the...
Main focus is the actual ABC work versus the D work, you know.
Yeah, I mean.
Yeah, that's what my observation else I would like to share there, because I'm observing both Maxwell and Valor performance. When I do see the number increasing, right, they're doing pretty good. So if they are aligned, that's my suggestion. I mean, probably will not probably not go with the replacement path, because if they are doing good, whatever is required, they're delivering.
And they are older in the system, so they know in and out. It'll be more easy than to, you know, take care of the task and to the new person starting from the scratch, so...
and monitoring both to make sure they're aligned.
Right, so PTO, yeah, thank you Liz for PTO first, so Kundan and Junal has the plan PTO Aman that we got to this, yeah, I haven't added that, so we have the coverage for both when they're out, Varak is going to cover during when Junad is out, and for Kundan, yeah, there's no coverage required.
Vernin, Abdul, so I think the we completed one week kind of process training for them, right, to make sure they're aligned, they're following what Milner has the process, so they are aligned. I personally connected with the both, and of course went through all the...
anything that they need further information. Technical side, they are pretty good. I don't find any gap when it comes to fixing anything, an issue or anything. Yeah, I'm just I think the process data, so they are aligned both.
But we'll talk about the numbers, so just put two weeks of data to just compare from May 10th to May 16th and May 17th to May 23rd. So Janet has always overall total utilization 79%, 10th to 16. Last week was 70.30% closed.
Forty-two tickets. Kundan, yeah, and if I look for a Kundan trend, normally forty-five percent, but yeah, fifty-two percent to 50%. Maxwell, yeah, eighty-eight percent to 90%. Wheeler is again matching the same number what Maxwell has, so eighty-eight last week, and...
74.
Vernie, I made good progress, 42% to 44%. He was out for two days due to an emergency, so three day he worked last week. Abdul was out for two days on the 10th to 16 weeks, so 65%, and last week 45%. So he switched recently to the weekend shift.
the shift rolled over that we completed. Anything that you notice, Linden Lewis, from your side?
or any suggestion, anything that we have become closely working on learning of those side to at least they should upcoming week cross 60% at least the total utilization and then later what the target that we have defined 80%.
So then one clarity question for the weekend shift. I think we discussed this earlier service call that we are planning something that they can take care of on the weekend. Weekdays I think they are pretty good, but on the weekend when they have a time, anything that they can take care of, any other tickets or any D types of work which they can.
I work on a weekend.
I still see when they have some time where we can utilize them to get additional value added on the weekend shift.
Yeah, I mean, they're pretty much in the same scenario as Valor and Maxwell. If you're working on the weekends, Saturday, Sunday, as long as the ABC work is taken care of and handled, then I don't see a problem as far as doing exactly what Maxwell and Valor are doing.
CX.
Mhm.
Keeping themselves busy with other stuff, you know, to increase their utilization in that area.
Yeah, sure. Yeah, I will update both for the same.
Wait, I think that's what it from my side. Lee, Amit, anything from your side that you want to add or...
No, the only thing is to focus on the AB work 1st and then moving to C&D to make sure that we are filling in any time that we're left with is will remain as a focus. I guess, Lewis, what we will do, we will circle back to you and Linden looking at.
the type of tickets and the ratio of the tickets in ABC that Maxwell and Vaid are currently pulling in.
If we see that the balance is not right, then of course we'll align with Aman and probably come back to you with the recommendation that what should be the next step and move ahead, like we discussed during the last meeting as well.
So, just for framing, so I understand, is the is the concern that Max and Vaylor aren't picking up Helpdesk facing work?
Is that kind of the the overall?
Our, our.
And we're working on that.
Yeah, our overall perception is we want to make sure that the work that's being performed by the engineers is deemed value work, right? Busy, busy work as a very last resort, what Milner considers valuable, what Milner considers busy work. So a lot of the discussions have been around, you know.
Right.
Sure.
Service desk first, then do this, then do this. And even within service desk, there's, you know, there's the help desk, tickets that come in, and what's the priority level. And so we broke down a lot of that when I was there in person, and I brought it back to the team, shared A lot.
Aman, I know you've reviewed this with the team, by the way. I was going to say, please make sure you're reviewing A, B, and C work with them on a weekly basis, right? Here's what that looks like. But yeah, the short answer, Paul, is yes. We're trying to make sure we're evaluating the value proposition of those engineers on that shift.
Yep.
Okay.
Because this should come back up when we talk pricing, because I know Valer and Max are spendier, right? So they should be on harder work, especially Maxwell should be on harder tasks. And if he's the wrong person in the wrong chair, then I kind of, I'm on track, it makes sense. But.
Yep.
That's essentially the discussion that we're having is like, what's the level of complexity that we can and will be looking to mid and long term adjust to that shift? I know there's some change management work that's been talked about, but even that, executing standard change management is not necessarily going to be the most complex work. A lot of times it's.
Okay.
Right.
Yeah, but no, realistically though, we have, you know, we have tons and tons of more complex technical work on the back end that does not get addressed. And I know that's not Helpdesk facing and that's not.
setting and babysitting.
Service desk facing necessarily.
So, as we go into these disk.
But historically, Maxwell has done really good notes in his ticket. I feel like he's reached a point in the career where it's more like he probably turns his nose up a little bit at like Helpdesk user facing basic work. Not to not be mean about it, I just think that from interacting with him in passing, I think that's kind of where he is.
Yeah.
And that doesn't mean he's not a value, it just means he's not maybe the best.
So, from...
Ford, hey, please go fix all those user problems.
So I agree with you and let me just toss out there, you know, this is a known challenge we've all been discussing for a little while. So the question that I would pose back is how do we open up availability of scope without undermining?
Oh.
the current business need of the Helpdesk where he's assigned, or does it make sense to do a reassignment and a realignment? Because we can move Maxwell to other tasks, but we've got a Helpdesk need to support as well. You've got to, you know, so I absolutely think we can and should, especially if we come back and we say, hey, look.
Right, it's a head count question.
Yeah.
listen, like for the cost and the work that load that we see and what we can make the progress on, we recommend doing this adjustment. And Paul, you absolutely should be part of that discussion because if there's opportunity to adjust and shift Maxwell elsewhere.
then we should be talking about it, right? But what we don't want to do is we don't want to have a being a cost center sitting on the weekends. You know what I mean?
Yeah, because the...
Right, the problem I see is that we're completely recalibrating around getting that ticket count down, which is good because that's where the fire is. But once and if that's under control and it goes, hey, okay, that's under control. And now why are there, you know, 600 red alerts still sitting on an alert dashboard? Because I can turn more and more on. We don't have most of it on.
Right, right.
Yeah.
We can't regain the Maxwell, like, like...
He's got the tribal knowledge. I don't know. It's a conversation, it's a separate conversation really, but we'll talk about it when we when we go over the pricing and and engineer proposal stuff, yeah.
Let's do that and make sure, yeah, maybe we'll make sure Kris is there for that, because I do think this is a worthwhile discussion. I just think we should target it in its own conversation. Yeah, thanks, Paul.
Yeah.
Pre.
Great, thanks, Steve. We're good. Thank you for all your time and enjoy the rest of the day and have a great weekend. We'll see you next week.
Yeah.
Thanks, Johal.
Yeah, pleasure seeing you all.
Thank you.
Thanks, everyone. Bye.
Thanks, Arora.
Thank you. Bye.
Cheers.